الروسيه في المنطقه بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
معارك مستمره شمال مدينه باخموت الشرقيه
حيث استعادت القوات الاوكرانيه ما يقرب من
كيلو و400 متر من الاراضي كما تحولت
الخطوط الاماميه في المنطقه من مركز
الدفاع الى الهجوم وفق ما اشارت له صحيفه
واشنطن بوست في وقت سابق حيث سيكون الهدف
الرئيسي للجيش الاوكراني كسر الدفاعات
الروسيه في الجنوب وقطع كل سلاسل الامداد
عن الجيش الروسي انطلاقا من شبه جزيره
القرم وجنوب روسيا وبالتالي فالاستسلام
سيكون مساله وقت وفق خبراء عسكريين ووفق
مراقبين ستكون هذه المرحله الاكثر دمويه
في الحرب التي تدخل عامها الثاني ومن
المتوقع وقوع خسائر كبيره في كلا الجانبين
مع استمرار الهجمات المكثفه ولذلك سيكون
الرهان على من له قدرات دفاعيه اكبر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات